[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
should capital rioters face murder or
other felony charges
these were people who were very
determined to come into our capitol
building
and really do some harm and they did a
closer look into the horrific video
during the insurrection former
minneapolis police officer derek shovin
is ordered to stand trial by himself for
the death of george floyd
the other three ex-cops must now wait
until this summer
a breakdown of how both trials will
proceed plus could the death of laurie
vallo's brother be connected to the
deaths of her two children
what police are now saying about the
doomsday cold case
alex cox we believe and authorities
believe
is the one that likely killed jj
entirely and
a judge stays the execution of the only
female prisoner on death row
but could her execution still be carried
out i think that we are at a point where
we know
that more punishment is not always more
justice
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law on crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
federal authorities are warning of
possible attacks planned at state
capitals across the country
as video of the assault on the nation's
capital captured the deadly insurrection
ryder stormed the steps of the capitol
building on january 6.
a mob seen pushing towards the front
doors as an officer's shield is taken
[Music]
this video taken by a group called
status quo appears to show the mob using
pepper spray and tasers
[Music]
one officer becoming trapped between the
doors
the group continuing to push forward
the officer now without his mask is
bleeding and screaming for help
dc's acting police chief says that the
officer was able to free himself
and is recovering
[Music]
it makes me sick to my stomach to see
that that video
and that officer obviously he was afraid
for his life
more than 100 riders now face local and
federal charges
there were several items of property mpd
property district government property
that was stolen
from him thankfully his weapon was not
taken from him 56 d.c metro officers
were injured
one losing his life officer brian siknik
reportedly succumbing to his
injuries after being beaten with a fire
extinguisher
his fellow officers paying tribute to
him in front of the very building he
died protecting
i believe again that mpd members
performed valiantly
along with a lot of our local partners
in in the ncr the other law enforcement
agencies
that were there with them uh i have
talked to officers that said who have
uh done two tours in iraq and said that
this
has was was was more was scarier to them
than their time in combat
our officers were in a fight not just
for their lives but for the democracy of
this country
officials with the department of justice
are speaking out publicly for the first
time
since the riots and say the initial
charges filed are simply the easiest
ones
expect more and expect upgrades
we're looking at significant felony
cases tied to
sedition and conspiracy just yesterday
our office organized a strike force of
very senior national security
prosecutors
and public corruption prosecutors their
only marching orders from me are to
build seditious and conspiracy charges
related to the most heinous
acts that occurred in the capital and
these are significant charges that have
felonies with a prison terms of 20 up to
20 years
in addition to that we're looking in
taking a priority with
cases in which weapons were involved and
cases in which destructive
devices were involved as people know
through news reports
there were pipe bombs found outside the
capitol the atf
is working on that metro police is
working on that fbi's working on that to
find that individual or individuals
who planted those devices
joining me now is criminal defense
attorney imran ansari along with terry
austin imran we heard it there
the doj is saying that seditious
conspiracy is on the table
can you break down that charge for us
sure brian that is uh pursuant to u.s
code section 2384
and it essentially criminalizes any
conspiracy
to quote overthrow put down or destroy
the government by force
and prevent hinder or delay the
execution of any law of the u.s
or by force seize take or possess any
property of the u.s
now we have tons of video here we have
tons of evidence
that shows that this essentially mob uh
took
the capital and i think it's arguable
and
pretty strong to say that sedition is
made out
by what we see on many videos and but
what we will hear from many witnesses
who were at the capitol that day and you
hear from the u.s attorney's office
that all bets are off everything is on
the table
and i think that well what you see here
is a strong case for this
edition and the u.s attorney's office
they're not going to be shy about
bringing those charges
now terry imran kind of touched on it
but from a prosecutorial standpoint
this ride's a little different than
others in that these writers are
literally bragging
on video giving interviews social media
about what they did
what do you expect on some of these
sentences for these potential defendants
brian you know these attacks were brazen
they were blatant
and the nature of the crimes is such
that both state and federal prosecutors
have said that they will be punished to
the fullest extent of the
law these individuals literally stormed
the capital with the intent to cause
harm they attacked police officers they
planted pipe bombs
and they were apparently prepared to
take hostages and we know that
individuals have died so charges could
reign from
anything theft to i mean as imran said
sedition
and in fact they could face charges of
felony murder and
they could go to prison for life thanks
terry imran
still ahead on lawn crime daily new
documents out in the lorry vallo and
chad davil case
and we've got them here for you but
first
find out exactly when the former
officers will go to trial for the death
of george floyd
the shocking decision made by the judge
after the break
new information in the trials of the
four former officers charged with
murdering george floyd
we now know one will go to trial in
march and the other three will be tried
together
later this summer a judge in minnesota
has ordered derek shovin stand alone for
the death of george floyd
floyd died last may after officers
kneeled on his neck for more than eight
minutes
jury selection is scheduled to begin on
march 8 and opening statements are set
for march 29th
the three other officers two tal thomas
lane and j
alexander king are scheduled to be tried
together on august 23rd
the judge's order lists out the number
of preemptory challenges or objections
to possible jurors without cause
each side will get for chauvin's trial
the defense will have 15
and the state will have nine for the
august trial each defendant will have
five
for a total of 15 the state will again
have nine
back with me our attorneys terry austin
and imran ansari terry why were the
cases broken down three officers and
chauvin and can you explain the
differences in the numbers
of peremptory challenges you know brian
as for the separation of the case is
under rule 14 of the criminal rules of
procedure the court can grant severance
of cases for defendants
to avoid any possible prejudice and here
the judge must have concluded
that trying the three officers with
officer chovin
would have been prejudicial remember
chovin gave the order
and he was directly involved with george
floyd's death
you know as for the preemptory
challenges you know that means that you
can challenge
for any reason and you don't have to
give the reason the judge split the
charges
equally i believe so essentially the
defense has
15 challenges in both trials and nine
challenges for
the prosecution now imran you've
represented high profile clients
if you're representing chauvin what's
the mindset after hearing this severance
and how it's going to work out in terms
of trials sure brian well i'm happy
because you know that uh
shogun's attorneys did move for
severance last year and that was denied
now
you have a severance based on a covet
concern
so i'm taking this as a win from his
attorneys and i'm uh
resting a little easy because you know
that the co-defendants there
um really are going to have antagonistic
defenses they're going to be looking to
point the finger
at derek shovin sort of distance
themselves from this alleged crime
and uh the trial could uh really resolve
with some prejudice if you had all the
defendants together now derek chovin um
if i'm looking at this case as his
defense attorney
i'm saying okay let's concentrate on the
charges against him
let's establish that there was no intent
and that these charges are not well
placed
and i'm looking to defend my client and
my client alone
definitely a lot cleaner maybe the
defense for chauvin is looking at this
as a victory
and of course the other three defendants
get to point the finger and maybe see
the tracks that are laid
in the march trial before those start in
august
and in other top legal news the colorado
attorney general
is opening a grand jury investigation
into the death of elijah mclean
mclean died in 2019 after being placed
in a chokehold by officers
then sedated by paramedics police say a
person had reported that he looked quote
sketchy mclean yelled he was an
introvert that he was different
and begged for help now state officials
are launching an independent
investigation
into the officer's use of force an
attorney for mclean's family wants to
know
why first responders administered
ketamine a powerful
anesthetic he did not have supernatural
strength as you can see from the video
he is completely restrained under a pile
of law enforcement officers
by the testimony of the officers about
700 pounds worth of cops were on top of
this 140 pound man
who was begging for his life and saying
that he couldn't breathe
so he certainly didn't exhibit that he
was uh responding appropriately he was
identifying himself
he was saying his name that he was
trying to go home
that he hadn't done anything wrong that
he didn't have a weapon
and they still administered this drug
which was
medically totally inappropriate and that
was a constitutional violation
of his right to bodily integrity we
cannot legally be given
medication against our will and that's
what happened here
the grand jury 12 to 23 people will have
the power to subpoena witnesses
even the authorities did an interview
coming up on law and crime daily a stay
of execution granted to the only woman
on death row
could be overturned plus our experts
break down the latest news in the
doomsday cult case
what police are saying about more deaths
surrounding the duo
next
[Music]
a new report out in the so-called
doomsday cult duocase is shedding light
into the investigation of the deaths of
two children
law and crime's terry austin has been
pouring through the 59-page report and
has the latest for us
brian the gilbert police have just
released information into the death of
one of the suspect's brother
alex cox lori valo and her husband chad
dabel
are facing charges of conspiracy to
conceal and destroy
evidence in the deaths of valo's two
children
the bodies of j.j valo and tyler ryan
were discovered buried in a shallow
grave
on chad dabell's idaho property
investigators believe valo's brother
alex cox
is tied to the children's deaths
according to the report
cox died on december 12 2019 from
natural causes such as blood cots and
high blood pressure
but long crime executive trial producer
kathy russon notes
strange circumstances surround cox's
death
alex had not been feeling well and he
was getting short of breath and winded
very easily
and on the day of his death he called
chad day bell and chad davao gave him a
blessing over the phone in the mormon
belief
system that priesthood holders can give
you blessings for um to get better
for help um when you're sick chad gave
him a blessing over the phone
then either chad or lori called dilemma
and said alex is really sick you should
check on him she was at work
she called her adult son that was living
in the house
and said check on alex i can't get a
hold of him and that's when the adult
son went and found alex on the floor
barely breathing vomiting of frothing at
the mouth
he lost control of his bowels like he
was on death's door
this is december 2019 the kids are
missing and chad and lori have fled to
hawaii
and they're in hawaii in december of
2019 when alex
dies we're getting analysis with defense
attorney imran ansari and terry austin
terry connect the dots for us does this
bring us any closer to answering how jj
valo
and tyler ryan died no brian
unfortunately i don't think we are any
closer to knowing how these children
died we know that jj was wrapped in
plastic and bound by duct tape
and that tiley was dismembered and
burned but we don't have details
about how they were actually killed you
know as for the cause of
death for alex after reading the lengthy
police report and listening to
the very long 9-1-1 call it does seem
as though he may have died of natural
causes
he was found by you know zlima's son
joseph
who tried very hard to save his life and
based on the police report and what you
know kathy said
zulima his wife said that alex was
suffering from shortness of breath
and slightness of breath prior to his
death so
it does seem as though his death was
natural
now imran for those of us that are
watching law and crime
i'm going to know about this information
about alice cox our audience is going to
know about it but are they going to hear
it in the jury
when these two go to trial
brian i would say no because i really
don't see the relevance as to the
charges that
the defendants are uh are facing this
would be a sort of superfluous evidence
in my opinion and i don't think that it
would be coming in uh
or would have any relevance if anything
it paid sort of a a distraction and i
would be arguing on their behalf them
being the defendants
that this evidence really has no place
in this trial and i'm going to keep it
out and i think the rules of evidence
are
are going to agree with that yeah i
would agree with you as well imran
they've got to connect a dot
terry do you see maybe some information
that could make it relevant because i'm
agreeing with imran so far
no i agree with both of you i don't
think his death i mean
had it been ruled you know not natural i
think it might have some relevance here
but since they ruled that it was natural
and since it seems it was
i don't think that it's going to get in
all right of course we're going to keep
eyes on the valo day bell cases and
we'll give you those updates as they
come in
when we come back should federal
authorities execute a female inmate for
the first time in 70 years
we look into the last minute appeals
filed in the case
a woman scheduled to be executed for
cutting a baby out of a young woman's
body killing her
gets a temporary reprieve angenette levy
spoke with lisa montgomery's attorney
about why they say her life should be
spared
you know brian lisa montgomery's lawyers
they are not asking that she be released
from prison they simply want her
sentence commuted to
life in prison without the possibility
of parole now the reason that they're
arguing this is they say that montgomery
suffers from mental illness brought on
by years of
childhood trauma including severe sexual
abuse
her lawyers believe that contributed to
her killing bobby joe stinnett in 2004.
montgomery had set up an appointment
with it at her home in skidmore missouri
to see a dog she was breeding
montgomery strangled stinnett and then
cut her abdomen open with a knife and
stole her eight-month-old fetus
that baby girl survived and is today 16
years old
she became profoundly mentally ill
she developed a psychotic disorder
uh and that led directly to the crime
for which she was convicted and
sentenced to death
lisa accepted responsibility for her
crime
she has has has expressed
deep remorse in her moments of lucidity
but that doesn't answer the question of
whether she should be executed for her
crime
i think that's a very important
distinction to draw
now montgomery has also asked the white
house to commute her sentence to life in
prison without the possibility of parole
and there are some
organizations and some celebrities
advocating
for her execution to be stopped citing
her mental health
as the main reason not to move forward
with that execution
i don't think anybody who is advocating
on behalf of lisa
is indicating that the loss that was
experienced
by the the victim's family is any less
or trying to minimize that in any way
our understanding
is that lisa was incredibly mentally ill
and traumatized at the time that this
crime was committed
now a federal court in indiana where
this execution is scheduled to take
place
actually issued a stay saying that a
hearing on montgomery's competency
needed to be held to see if this
execution should move forward the
department of justice actually
appealed that stay to the seventh
circuit of court of appeals in chicago
and one
so this execution could possibly move
forward there were actually two other
states circulating in other appellate
courts and the department of justice is
also appealing those to the u.s supreme
court
i also reached out to bobby joe
stennett's family i have not heard back
from them but we know that they traveled
to the prison in terre haute to witness
the execution
brian no internet you said earlier the
baby survived in this case do we know
how she's doing today
you know we've been trying to find out
um i reached out to the family as i
mentioned
and that's the student family by all
accounts we've looked around and we
haven't seen
any recent interviews with any of those
family members they've been incredibly
private about this
i actually reached out to the sheriff
who was the detective in the case back
when this happened as well and he did
not respond
so we know that they have been
incredibly private and have not
commented publicly
in some time thanks anjanet now imran
there's some back and forth because the
court didn't really say
no execution they just said not till a
competency hearing
is completed but with president-elect
joe biden coming into office
could this mean that montgomery will
never be executed
well brian um i would imagine once
there's the transition of
power and i hope that it's peaceful
peaceful um
this will be uh on the docket again and
you know this is really coming down to
the constitutional question under the
eighth amendment
uh is this a cruel and unusual
punishment um does she have the mental
capacity
that makes her fit for execution if you
will and i think that's going to be a
question before the court we know that
there's a stay
and the competency hearing is going to
go forward at some point
and then a decision is going to have to
be made understood now
terry it was down to the wire from
montgomery what's your reaction to the
court's decision
and her future well you know as
angenette said the 7th circuit
actually overturned judge hanlon's
decision
they said that the attorneys for
montgomery waited too
long to bring up this challenge as far
as competency is concerned
but i was surprised to see that the
judge did
stay her execution because you know the
eighth amendment
says that you cannot execute someone who
due to their mental illness don't
understand
the basis of their execution but my view
all along was that she should have been
held
incompetent to stand trial and as we
know she did stand trial and she was
convicted so
i thought that the argument was going to
lose and the seventh
circuit actually ultimately did agree
that that argument should not prevail
yeah and of course they still have those
two pending petitions we'll see how
those play out
but like i said new president could mean
a new outcome
terry and jeanette imran thank you for
joining us and thank you for joining us
here at long crime daily we'll see you
next time on discuss justice in america
[Music]
you